uh magnus has to be cautionary my plan
was simple this is what course noise
says to deprive karpov as his favorite
occupation standing at the board staring
straight at his opponent while i was
wearing these glasses all he could see
was his own reflection because he was
wearing mirrored sunglasses
all sorts of okay so we have some moves
a few checks on the board
yeah this is uh
okay magnus came from with the white
king did i just see the hand kind of
yeah make that draw offer oh there we go
draw offer and it is a draw
game two in the world championship match
is also a draw magnus crossing with the
white pieces what a dramatic and
exciting game we have gotten from dubai
today but it is
eventually a draw and a big smile on
magnus's face wow what do you think they
were talking about
i'm hoping we can hear either
sorry i think you're taking d4 off
yeah there's the material sound like
this yeah
uh here's some sign there was some
i think you take on d5
neither player too happy there
exhaling
i think they were just discussing the
opening even very early in the game
that's very
i just couldn't calculate but you are
giving up the queen and i think
i can't give it away on uh this is
because i play queen e7 cash for queen
h4
yeah i have some counter players let's
show you already
at some point you could attack like on
probably this
this wouldn't work but maybe you know
i thought like c3 is like is a nice way
just to make sure i'm not getting mated
maybe
maybe for the subject of a strong yeah
now after bc3 i mean i'm
also maybe looking into it i was
stronger
than rick yeah
because after looking g8 maybe
maybe white can't do much but i thought
that would be it is very good okay
suddenly it's bush before it goes
yeah
i mean
i have no idea if it's better
live from dubai you guys these two
players discussing the game afterwards a
lot of notation david